What are some of the goals of
the authentication process itself?
So remember, authentication in
a nutshell is a user convincing a system
who he or she is, so
using some technique or some method.
So obviously we're talking about the
user associated with a certain identity.
Username for example, wanting to
authenticate herself to the system.
Whatever authentication method we use,
what do we desire from it,
what should be its goal?
First of all, when a legitimate
user tries to authenticate herself,
the system can demand some evidence but
when the right evidence is provided,
the system should allow the login
to complete successfully.
Well, that is called availability, okay?
The system is available to the user
who's able to provide the right evidence
to support the claim, for
example, the user is Alice.
So the system should be
available to the legitimate
user who is able to provide
the correct evidence.
In other words, we don't want
to have any false negatives.
So let's just spend a little bit
of time on what do we mean by
this phrase false negative
that I have here.
So negative refers to the outcome.
So if the authentication process
is successfully complete,
that is a positive outcome.
A negative outcome is when we deny
the authentication request or
the login request.
So if, for some reason,
believe the evidence is not right or
whatever it is, so we're going to say
login unsuccessful, for example, or
authentication unsuccessful.
If it's the right user providing
the right evidence and
the system still has a negative outcome,
well that is incorrect.
In fact, that outcome we see is not
a correct outcome, that result is false.
The user was the right one
with the right evidence.
Whatever method we're using,
perhaps, has a problem and
because of that it's not
able to allow the user in.
So if the outcome is negative and
that's done incorrectly that
is called a false negative.
So false negative basically means
when we incorrectly deny access or
incorrectly decline an authentication
request, we don't want to have that.
We have an authentication method,
we don't want it to deny
authentication requests for right
users who provide the right evidence.
Well the other possibility
is the bad person,
Eve, is trying to impersonate her.
So Eve walks up to the system and
says I am Alice.
So it's the user principal that
is associated with identity,
which is Alice.
It's really not her and it's Eve, so
the user or principal who is not
associated with Alice identity,
we don't want that person,
or Eve, to be able to login.
Well, if you had a guarantee,
then we have authenticity in
the authentication process.
If we authenticate someone, we know for
sure that it is that person, so
that's the authenticity part.
And another way to sort of think about
this is that we don't want to have any
false positives.
So positive here refers to the outcome
of the authentication process.
Positive means we allow someone
to login or authenticate.
And false means we
actually make a mistake.
We do that incorrectly.
If Eve is able to login as Alice,
that is not right.
That is incorrect.
So that's a false positive.
So we don't want to have
any false positives.
The second goal that we have for
authentication is that
the right user with the right identity
and evidence should be allowed in.
That means we have no false negatives,
and
somebody who is going to
impersonate a user of the system
should not be allowed in which means
we should not have any false positives.
So these are the goals of
a good authentication method
that you would want to
implement in your system.